I was a fan of Theodore since I was a
little kid you know I used to see my dad
playing soccer in Diadora shoes and I
always thought the brand was kind of
cool back in the 90s but this is a
different approach seeing that they're
making retro tech product in Italy is
like expensive and the fact that they're
willing to still do that today is kind
of amazing to me so I always wanted to
be a part of that since they started a
couple years ago I went to Italy to go
to their headquarters it was basically a
walk through their timeline the product
and the quality of the product is like
always the most important to me how
seriously they took themselves back then
and how seriously they take themselves
today just made me want to work with
them more
this is the RF 7000 it is a spinoff of
their original 7000 which we brought
back from their catalog the one thing I
took from the archive room was this
asymmetrical toe that they had on a
track elite it was one of those things
that I saw and I right away knew would
be a game-changer for me and Diadora
mixing that in with the materials in the
colorway of the shoe I think is super
exciting I think it's a breath of fresh
air not only for the brand but for retro
tech runners in general we slept in our
F 7000 logo usually it's the 7000 logo
but since I added this asymmetrical toe
it really changed the look of the shoe
so then let me name it after my initials
the color way to me is very special I
wanted to do something off of the
Italian flag but I thought that the
Italian flag had colors that were a
little too harsh to wear every day
instead of going white green red we went
with off-white olive and burgundy
thought it was a little more wearable
you get a little more use out of it out
in Italy we opened up a bunch of
different lace books and I found this
one lace that I really like and it's
this woven rope cotton woven rope this
just gives it a different type of
texture and different volume so looks a
little thicker and I wanted that because
the leather is used on the shoe
represents more of like a boot leather
there are four laces that come with the
shoe the first one is the beige in
burgundy that comes tied in and then the
other three options are burgundy olive
olive off-white and then an all-white
place I don't believe that people know
what goes behind making specific product
you know we just see the end result or
the consumer sees the end result but
they're not they're at the factory
seeing how things are made and on this
asymmetrical piece there's this faux
stitch that kind of finishes the mock
that goes all the way around having to
stitch it over the shoe and then stitch
around the mock to really finish it off
it was a little bit of an issue in the
beginning and it was a big design
element that I wanted to implement so we
went back and forth until they got it
right I'm seeing a lot of companies
suffer in terms of quality control the
investment that Diadora has made into
factories in Italy is is unprecedented
they wouldn't be possible if it wasn't
handmade in Italy you know they're
perfect